Mắt đi nếu phố là trong cuộc sĩ quến thị hoa, quen nghề an, gần 2.5 lạm dị việc anh không chỉ quan với cuộc sống cùng vộ,
mà còn yêu cả tính nghệ, ông thực và con với quen cầu. 2 người gặp nhau năm 2019 trong một lần mắt đing sáng Việt Nam
chơi cùng mạng. Cuộc gặp ở nữ sau đó cho thành buối quan hệ lâu dài, rồi một cuộc hôn nhân suyên biên giới.
Nhưng đều khiến như quỳ càng thấy thú vị và yêu quỳ chính là cách mắt đing hoa nhập, thậm sĩ hoa tàn với quen khu vợ.
Vì vộ chỉ nấu mỏng Việt, mắt thiên dần quan tị, rồi mê lúc nào không hành.
Anh ở ý đặt Việt hiện đất mắm, hoa quen nói, đớ ăn nào anh có hỏi nước mắm, thậm sĩ thì cầu nước kêu tay anh có chấm nước mắm và kê ngọt.
Bớ nước mắm không? Đức mắm mạng.
Nếu anh đi vụ nếu như thế này.
Bớt anh không ăn đưa hả?
Bớt anh không ăn truyền thống.
Chẳng gì cũng bất còn xử hữu khả năng nói tiếng để ăn rồi.
Anh học từ vợ qua sau tiếp hàng này không qua chử lúc nhưng nói rất tự nhiên.
Những câu nói đậm giống để ăn khiến ăn với cũng bật kỳ vì qua sinh.
Đi đâu tiếng để ăn là chi?
Vậy, em, làm gì?
Như, phí, xí, xí ơi!
Vình thầy biển gần, hả mình đem qua bột trong quà đã bị Việt Nam hơn.
Mắtzie nhập sựa thầy máy với họ hàng, teri tý tối mẹ vụ vào có để難 yên tối nồi, dạ hả?
Bôi hoa, điều khiến cô hình phúc nhất không phản để lấy trường tây, mà là trong mình thực sự yêu và chấm chấm phần hán đưa cô sinh ra.